The Joe Rogan experience. We should probably tell people what happened.
If people who don't know don't pay attention, you and Burt were doing this dunk.
C challenge. We, so we were shooting content for our live show,
which was a new year's Eve live. So that was like exciting.
We had done one before where, um, we played tennis and we, you know,
we had like just goofy. There's around. And we shot some sketches and stuff.
So we, we have this idea. We're like, we competed, let's compete,
let's do basketball. And then we'll do a dunk contest.
We'll lower the rim and raise it and see who can dunk on the highest rim.
And that'll be part of the competition, you know?
Oh, how dare.
You? Just as actually dunking, this was the video.
He just put out what they were doing before. Oh yeah. That's that day. Yeah.
That's that day. How high is that one? That one's like eight. Right?
And then what's regulation 10. And you dunk at 10?
No, I, I dunked at nine though. So I beat Bert.
So this is like eight and a half right there. And then the,
this is nine right here. Right. So I beat him. He couldn't do it.
And it was over that's over right there. And then you did, so right there,
they're all like holy. And Bert's like, holy. Cause he couldn't do it.
And I'm like, oh, it's over. And there's Tristan jazz. We went with,
he's like a really talented kid basketball. I, I won, won, excuse me. I won.
And uh, and then right after for this, one of those guys goes,
uh, I think you got, you can go a little higher. And I was like,
I remember I, I felt the adrenaline, you know, when someone's like,
you got this and you're like, like,
you feel like your throat kind of tighten up. Yeah. You know, and that was,
they raised it three inches. That's it from, from that nine three. So, you know,
just cuz I, I, I, I didn't have a lot more room. I was like, oh, that was like,
it was clean. But I was like, I can't, I can't go that much higher.
And just on the push off, push off on the left foot,
my left patella tendon snapped. Now, did.
You strain.
It before that? Not that I knew of. I mean,
eventually when I talked to the doctor about it, he was like,
this probably would've happened. Like doing something else. What? Yeah.
Why? He's just like, you know, he,
he said it was such a strange place for the tear to take place.
He's like, it took a first, he goes, he goes, you know,
it took a tremendous amount of force to, to do what you did.
How did you do this? I was like a dunk contest.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> and he was like, what? <laugh>?
And I was like dunk contest. He was like a slam dunk contest. And I was like,
yeah, dude. And he was like, okay. He goes, well,
normally these patella tendons snap in like one or two places.
And like you are snapped in a place that it rarely happens in like it's not at
one of the attachment points. It was like a quarter of the way down. He's like,
it's very strange the way it snapped. Hmm.
So didn't you do like deadlifts or something? The.
Day before that I did squats three days before you saw.
When you went to the.
Dunking thing? No, no, we, I was doing 2 55, uh, sets of 12. Okay.
So not really heavy weight, not crazy weight. And like, I mean,
but not super light, but like, you know, being able to, I,
I didn't have a problem with it. Mm-hmm <affirmative> and then,
you know what I do remember this,
that someone reminded me of this afterwards at,
at my office that I do remember they were betting whether I could do
nine feet at the office. And some people were like, yes, no.
And I jumped in my office in like jeans and a t-shirt and touched the ceiling
there. And I was like, that felt funny.
Oh, something felt funny in your knee. Yeah.
Here's the thing about tendons and ligaments. Yeah. Especially ligaments.
When they snap, they don't hurt.
I, it didn't hurt at all. Yeah. It didn't hurt at all. They just give out,
it just gave out. And I don't know if I would've felt pain,
if it wasn't for landing on my arm and snapping my humorous in half.
And that pain was so severe, that was so hard to watch.
It was extraordinary pain. I, and then when.
Bert takes it, pulls it and.
Why did he do that? I, he was like, you're right. But I think he was,
everyone was in shock, but will you.
Should have he have done that? Is that bad to move your arm.
Like that? They, yeah. It's he do? You're not supposed to move it.
You're supposed to leave it there. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And I have radial nerve damage and that, you know,
some people would argue that it could be exacerbated by being moved,
but some people would say that, you know, it didn't uh, oh yeah.
Right there. Yeah. Yeah. It hurt so much,
man. I could only imagine it hurt so much. Um, I could only imagine.
And then you know that I, I did something pretty crazy. Uh,
so I went to a hospital immediately, right from the paramedics came.
And as soon as I, as soon as I got to that hospital, I looked around,
I don't know where I am or anything. I was like, I'm not staying here. So they,
why I just knew it was a hospital. Where were you? You wanna say?
I don't wanna say, but I just knew. I just knew instinctively. I was like,
mm-hmm really? Yeah. Memory's so, you know,
when you have like intense experiences, your memory's so sharp from it.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> like, I remember so every detail of like a month,
like everything. Wow. People I met, I remember everyone's name, you know? Whoa.
So I got that emergency room. I remember that Scott was in the bed next to me.
And then this, uh, nurse came in. We did x-rays,
you know, they put this straight brace on my leg. They're like, you know,
tendon snapped.
And then they did a horrible job wrapping this arm in like a makeshift
kind of splint brace, you know? And I was like,
and then they're just pumping me through. They're like, how much pain are you?
And I'm like, all of it. What are you talking about?
Like all the pain and they're giving me drugs.
And then they're like, well, you need to have surgery. You know? So I,
I called my primary physician and I was like, who should operate on me?
And he's like, dude,
like the two people I would send you to are outta town right now. I was like,
all right. So the emergency room doctor there is like,
I'll set you up with this person that can do surgery tomorrow. And I was like,
no, I'm not doing it here. Really? And I was like, I'm leaving.
And they're like, you wanna leave here? And I was like, yep. They're like your,
your leg and your arm are like completely Notre working. I was like,
I don't care. They're like, are you sure? And I go, yeah.
So Lindsay who works with me, who was there filming, like get in his car.
I mean, it was hard to like, you got a guy named Lindsay working for you. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Okay. He'll Hey, he'll hear this. Give it to him, man.
Give it to him. You might wanna change that name.
So he is he, he him? No, no pronouns. He's he? His pronoun.
He's very, he him and yeah. So this's his. Yeah. Yeah,
but he doesn't put it in his signature, but he is. He's a great guy. Um,
so Lindsay helps me get in the car. Sorry, Lindsay. Um, and he, uh,
drives me home. So I just go,
I go home with a broken in half arm and a leg that why didn't he take you to a
better hospital? It didn't, it didn't occur to any of us.
I didn't go take me to the hospital, go home.
So I went home and Bert and Leanne had like helped set up this
area in our house. Cuz Christina was like, you know, beside herself,
like so overwhelmed. And they were really were really great.
And I got on the couch and I slept on the couch. Oh my God.
And then the next morning Burt had hired. I was like,
find me one of the like wheelchair drivers. Like that takes people around.
He found a guy that for $50 picked us up in a
30 year old van and a 50 year old wheelchair. No. Yes. And I was like,
who the did you find? He's like, I don't know. <laugh> so he, you know, I,
I do, I, I tell him this, that I I'm always like, you know, I'm a, a role solo.
Like I'll be like, I, I I'll go by myself to things. I grabbed him. I was like,
don't you leave me in this family. <laugh> don't leave me. And he was like,
okay. Oh my God, how old was the guy driving the car, dude, he was,
he wreaked of cigarettes. His hair was so long that when he pushed me,
like in the wheelchair, his hair would like be on my back on my neck.
And I was like, God, but I was in so much pain that I was just like,
just grinding my teeth. He takes me to an orthopedic surgeon,
like to this off office. And when I wheel into the office, that guy goes,
what the are you doing here, man? And I go, what? He goes,
you need to go to the hospital like right now. And I go, really? He goes, yeah,
man, you need to go to the hospital right now. He goes,
I just saw like what the, the x-rays from last night, he goes, you, I mean,
just go, right right now immediately to the emergency room, I was like, okay.
He tells me, you know, this is gonna be easy to fix the tendons,
like the real work, but just go and it'll be,
it'll suck for a bit to wait and everything, but just go.
So then I go to Cedars in LA and then, you know,
you have to wait. And then we get into like the fast track and Bert, you know,
is with me. And then eventually I get into a room later that day.
And then two days later I have surgery and then, wow. And then from,
I stay there another few days. So what'd they do with you for those.
Two days?
It was like, I mean, they were pumping me full of drugs. They re wrapped my arm,
which so they had to take off the old rap, the rap. And I was like, no, dude.
And then reset it and rewrap it. Oh man. Yeah, that was,
that was so much pain. And then, then they operated and then, um,
a couple days later I go to a recovery place,
like a rehab recovery place for two weeks. So that's why, that's what, you know,
you're just alone all the time, you know? Yeah. And it's a, it's strange,
you know.
And the two days of waiting was just because they needed operating room.
Time or just like, uh, so I that's the other thing, uh,
I ended up getting like one of the best trauma surgeons.
So I was like in the trauma ward and,
and this like one of the most sought after trauma surgeon.
So I'm so lucky to get him. And I tell him that he's like, tell me, you know,
what happened? I tell him and I tell him I left that hospital and he goes,
let me tell you something. He goes, that is crazy.
But that's the one of the smartest things you've ever done. Wow. He was like,
that was really, really smart of you to do.
Imagine they.
Butchered you. Yeah. He goes, you know,
cuz it was basically like that these two operations are major operations and
like I have titanium plates in here, you know? And like.
What does a scar look like?
Um, it's just like, it's pretty gnarly. I mean.
Take your jar. Check it though. Yeah. See the whole thing
now long ago was this.
Uh, December 1st and the surgery was December 4th.
Bro. That is a crazy scar. So they went right through your bicep.
Yeah. And uh, I love that one of the guys again, pull.
That up, pull it up. That's.
Wild dude. And I still have like radial nerve damage, you know? Yeah.
Not damage. Excuse me, bruise. So it's gonna take,
like they said up to 16, 18 months,
like month by month, it gets a little better.
Like I couldn't pull my wrist up like this before. If I raised my hand,
it would just go like that.
When did this, when it become better.
Like a month ago when I can grip things, but I can't use my extenders.
Like my hand doesn't open.
All the way. So when you do you have to like do it?
Yeah. Or like I have to have to place it.
But when you place it, can you grab things? Yes. I can grab things. Can you do.
A chin up? No, definitely not. Wow. Yeah. Cause I'm, I'm,
I'm lifting weights like four or five days a week,
but it's all light and it has, it has like,
I just got permission to do for, for like months. It was 15 pounds. He was like,
you can only lift 15 pounds in this arm. Mm.
And then he gave me permission to go up. So I did 20 and if I did rows,
I can do like 25 30. But it's the, all, everything here, atrophy, you know,
like doubt the whole, the whole rotator cuff area soup much, much weaker.
It's it's weird. Like you're like, that's not heavy, but then it feels heavy,
you know? Oh, wow. You know, and same thing with like your leg.
Like I can do seated squats, holding weight here,
but I can't like put, you know, weight on my back. Right. Like, but, but it,
you know, you do it like little by little and you see the little changes.
Yeah. I've been through a gang of surgeries. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
I've had both my knees.
Reconstructed. Oh, so you, yeah.
But like when this thing was in a straight brace for six weeks,
when that thing came off, I mean, you look at my quad. It was just like gone.
It's weird. I was like.
Whoa. And you put it next to the other one. And you're like, oh my God.
Man. It's weird. I.
It happens. Yeah. It happens real fast. You know,
the whole thing is that the experience becomes like so intense. And I,
I don't think like I can communicate it to people fully who,
who haven't either experienced it or the only people who like totally get it,
like the intensity of the experience and how it affects you are the PTs. Mm.
Because they've seen it, they work with, you know,
orthopedic injuries every day.
Like they know that it affects you like physically, mentally, and emotionally.
Nobody prepares you for that. Yeah. So.
You have a full year and a half really before your left arm.
Right. They told me that, you know, they're like that leg.
They go consider that a year, like a year before. It's a,
what you were used to before the arm. It's like, they go,
they've seen the nerve stuff cuz your,
your nerve regenerates at one millimeter a day. So I don't have a dam.
I don't have like a, like a cut nerve, but they're like one millimeter a days,
you know, it's really, really small. Yeah. So they're like, yeah,
we've seen people recover in four months from their radial nerve stuff.
And then we've seen people that take like a 18 months.
It goes just up in the air.
Now did you, um, look into peptides or anything else? Yep.
Has any of that stuff helped.
You? I mean, I've taken them and uh, I, I feel better. I feel good. You know?
And I'm like, you know, I'm eating really clean. I'm.
I, you look good saying when I, as soon as I saw you, like you look thin. Yeah.
Oh, thanks, man. Your face looks healthy. <affirmative> yeah.
I feel, I feel good. And um, you know, the truth is,
I don't know what effect the peptides have I take them. Right. And, um, I,
I religiously like I follow that schedule mm-hmm <affirmative> but to me it all
feels like part of, kind of the ritual of rehab. Mm-hmm <affirmative> so like,
it's like it's part it's it's dieting, it's exercise, peptide,
like all that is part of the, a recovery.
And are you doing the rehab through a physical therapist?
Are you you doing yeah.
Yeah. I got a great one. How many days a week are you doing it? We,
we were at three days a week. Then we went down to two. Um,
and then like now I don't really need, I don't need rehab anymore on my leg.
I mean, I need to work out and get it stronger, which I do,
but I don't need her to, to rehab it. Dr. Karen Juer she awesome. Um,
but she's been doing some of my, uh, like shoulder, arm stuff, uh,
working on this, but the, the leg is pretty much like, just get it stronger now.
Yeah. You just.
Look normal when you're walking around. Yeah. You don't have a limp at all.
Yeah. Which was surprising. I was like, I wonder. Yeah.
It's only four months walk. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Isn't that crazy? Yeah. Yeah.
Catch new episodes. The Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video and
audio experience on Spotify. You can,
can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can download
episodes to save on data cost. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.